I've lost 13 pounds in three days I'm
just sweating it out and it's the
sickness Chris Cuomo is still going
through it
suffering some major symptoms after
being diagnosed with the corona virus
you suffer when you have this at home
unless you are ridiculously lucky
statistically and maybe karmically as
well the news anchor joined his CNN
co-workers Anderson Cooper and Sanjay
Gupta for a town hall special about
covin 19 and opened up about the
physical toll it's had on his body in
just a few days I've lost 13 pounds in
three days now I'm a big guy I started
off at 230 pounds my wife is feeding me
like you know we were still in the
dating phase you know so it's not like
I'm not I'm hurting nutrition I'm eating
and drinking constantly I'm just
sweating it out and it's the sickness
Chris added that his symptoms especially
his fever seemed to get worse as the day
goes on the Beast comes at night you
know as we know the health care workers
have taken to calling the virus the
Beast I understand why my fever has gone
up a couple of degrees and like the last
30 minutes nights are tough and I've
learned something and I didn't know
before it is responsible journalism to
say that 80% of people who get this
statistically wind up okay meaning they
don't go to the hospital they get
through it
it is not humanly responsible although
from an ethical perspective Chris was
officially diagnosed with kovat 19 on
Tuesday I tested positive scary yes as
you might imagine but better me than you
now he's reflecting on what he's learned
and what has helped him deal with the
symptoms chicken soup is not just
anecdotal that has worked for me I
believe I have been counseled to try to
endure fever as much as I can because
the fever is the body's fighting
mechanism now what I've also learned is
there is so much BS on the internet that
people are trying to peddle as cures
fake pills fake tonics and I think we
have to be very careful about people
preying on desperation the father of
three is still working streaming his
show out of his basement where he is
still in quarantine away from his
wife and their kids so yeah I've had
I've had a fever you've had a fever but
102 103 103 Plus that wouldn't quit and
it was like somebody was beating me like
a pinata
earlier this week he shared some scary
symptoms he was experiencing it was
freaky what I lived through last night
and it may happen again tonight doctor
says it may happen like five eight times
Chris said that it got so bad that he
actually hallucinate Adana thought he
was talking to his dad who died in 2015
and I was shivering so much chipped my
tooth for the Sun comes up I'm awake I
was up all night was well I'm telling
you I was hallucinating I said my dad
was talking to me I was seeing people
from college people I haven't seen it
forever was it was freaky what I lived
through last night and it may happen
again tonight doctor says it may happen
like five eight times you know I get it
now and if you match that with chest
constriction of people can't breathe I
totally get why we're losing so many
people and why our hospitals are so
crowded
but even with all of that Chris seems to
be in good spirits he even had a giggle
attack when he popped into his brother
and the governor of New York Andrew
Cuomo's briefing obviously the fever has
affected your mental capacity and yeah
[Music]